[MUSIC - DNCE, "CAKE BY THE
OCEAN"]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: Ladies and gentlemen,
please welcome Michael
Korbacher, director, Google
Cloud Germany, Austria,
and Switzerland.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MICHAEL KORBACHER:
Herzlich willkommen.
Welcome to Munich's first
Google Cloud Summit.
The future of Cloud is now.
It is not a question of if,
it's a question of when,
and when is now.
I have been a longtime
believer in Cloud technologies.
I'd probably date that
back to the late '90s.
At that time, I was
working for a company
called Compaq Computers.
And some of you might remember
that brand which was then
acquired by Hewlett-Packard.
At that time, I was privileged.
I was based in the
south of France,
and my job was to launch
what was called back then
an ASP Competence Center.
ASP stood for Application
Service Providers,
which was the early form of what
we call software as a service,
or SAS Competence Center today.
And I was privileged because
that place was located
somewhere between
Nice and Cannes,
somewhere in the hills, in a
place called Sophia Antipolis.
And the French used to refer to
Sophia Antipolis as the Silicon
Valley of Europe.
While I was doing that,
launching this competence
center, there were some
smart people thousands
of miles on the west in the
real Silicon Valley, busy doing
something else,
because they were busy,
Sergey Brin and Larry
Page, launching Google.
Now, I do not want
to compare efforts,
and I do not want
to compare results.
But I would say
some of the ideas
that we had around utility based
computing and server on demand
back then probably made it some
way into the Cloud of today.
For sure, what I
have taken forward,
is the passion for Cloud.
And I'm quite sure it's
this passion for Cloud that
has brought me here today.
My name is Michael
Korbacher, and I'm
running Google's Cloud
business for Germany, Austria,
and Switzerland.
Now, the time has
not stood still,
and Google has progressed
and we have progressed.
And if we look at from
what happened something
like 19 years ago in a
garage in the Silicon Valley
where people started pulling
together infrastructure held
together with LEGO
blocks, we're now
looking at an
infrastructure where
we're running numerous
services that have,
on a regular basis, more
than a billion users.
Think about Gmail.
Think about YouTube.
Think about Search.
Think about Maps.
Think about Play,
Android, and so on.
What an infrastructure it takes.
And all that based on
an idea and a mission
that I would call
rather ambitious.
A mission that said
in a simple form,
well, we're going to
take the internet.
We're going to
index the internet.
We let people search that
index, and we give them
relevant answers
to their searches
no matter where they
are on the planet,
ideally within milliseconds.
That was a big ambition
when you think about it,
to organize the
world's information
to make it universally
accessible and useful.
That's a very big
ambition when you
think about how the
internet evolved
and how the internet grew.
To make that happen,
there was probably
not a lot of off the
shelf products that would
make this mission come true.
Think about it.
What file system could actually
manage that volume of data
that you would create?
What networking gear
could actually handle
all this bandwidth required?
What product would
I use to search
this amount of unstructured
data and give people
replies within milliseconds?
How do I scale?
How do I scale out?
And how do I improve my
results using technologies
like machine learning or
artificial intelligence?
So when looking at this to
get to where we are today,
one of the requirements was
to drive constant innovation,
to explore a path that
nobody has gone before.
And that led to the
development of things
like the Google File System.
When we're talking
about BigQuery,
how do we search large
amounts of unstructured data?
When we think about developments
such as Kubernetes, container
based technologies, how
do we distribute workloads
across servers, data
centers, Clouds,
as well as making machine
learning more accessible,
and artificial intelligence
more accessible,
through frameworks
like TensorFlow?
Now the great news
is, in necessity
of fulfilling our mission, we've
created all this innovation,
and we've given it back to
the open source community.
And now we're taking all
this, the infrastructure that
serves billions, and the
tools that run Google,
and we're making this
available to companies
in the form of Google Cloud.
You might think, hm,
all right, that's great.
I'm a manufacturer.
I'm a retailer.
I'm a logistics
company, or I'm a bank.
Why do I care?
Well, you should care because if
you are a traditional company,
what sets you apart in
the past, which might be,
oh, I've got a big data center.
And in that big data center, I
run some really big enterprise
IT.
I might have been your
competitive advantage
in the past.
For some of you, this might
be a slight burden today
because one of the key
things that companies
need to be aware of, and that
maybe is your treasure, not
your data center, but the
data within that data center.
And how do you exploit?
How do you use?
How do you make better decision
from that data within your data
center?
And that often
requires the tools
that are available
in the public Cloud.
I don't think your
sense of urgency
is to take a workload from A to
B and then save 20% on the way,
or you name it.
That does not necessarily
imply a sense of urgency,
especially if you
think about companies
doing quite well as an
average across the region.
Your sense of urgency
is a different one.
You want to be prepared
for the future.
And you want to be using the
tools that your competition can
use as well.
And your competition
might be somebody
that you have not been
dealing with in the past.
That might be that
startup company
that takes their credit card,
goes to the Google Cloud,
registers on the portal,
goes to the console,
and within 90 seconds, spawns up
a thousand node Hadoop cluster.
They use it for 10 minutes,
and then it takes them
60 seconds to shut it down.
That is your competition today.
At the end of the
month, they will
find an invoice on
their credit card
statement for 12 and 1/2 minutes
of usage of Google Cloud.
This is the environment
that we're in today,
and this is your
sense of urgency,
whether you're a startup or
whether you're an established
company.
You want to stay ahead
of the competition.
You want to do that with the
latest tools available to you.
You want to look at
how you work together
and be more collaborative.
Increasing productivity
is everybody's challenge.
You want to be, at
the end of today,
more agile, more
reactive to changes
in the business, ideally you
want to be proactive, really.
And all that as you're
dealing with security threats
out there on the
internet, you want
to do all that, ideally,
and be more safe.
And this is where Google
and the Cloud can help.
For us, this region, Germany,
Austria, and Switzerland,
is one of the key
regions on the planet.
It's a center of innovation.
It's the home of many
multinational companies
that have global influence.
And this investment that we're
making, and this importance,
is reflected by the
investments we're making.
And one of the investments
we've announced three months ago
is local computing power.
It is our data
region in Frankfurt,
which has dramatically
reduced the latency
and opens up new opportunities
for application development
and application deployment
within the region.
And it helps companies to keep
their applications and data
close to their heart.
We're completely
committed to GDPR.
Who's busy with GDPR at this
point in time, the General Data
Protection Regulation?
Many.
So are we.
And we think this is a blessing.
So we're taking what used to
be a guidance from the European
Union, which was then
interpreted slightly
differently from all
the member states--
and then if you look at
the states within Germany,
they might have had
their own preferences.
We're taking that into a general
regulation which can help us,
and which will help us, and
we're completely committed
to this new regulation.
Another important
thing for Germany,
which has an impact
globally as well,
is our partnership with SAP.
We've got SAP here as well.
So I'm glad to have them here.
And it spawns three areas.
Engineering, how we work
together to help the industry.
It's running SAP's technology
on our Google Cloud Platform.
As well as our partnership
around compliance,
where SAP helps
our joint customers
by monitoring services
and making sure
that they are delivered
to the service,
delivery and
quality as required.
Cloud is used by many
companies across the globe.
Don't worry, I'm not going to
talk about every logo here.
You will know most
of these logos.
And you will probably think,
gee, some of those logos,
they look rather conservative,
some of those companies.
I didn't know that they
were looking at Cloud.
I can tell you they are.
The Cloud is real.
The Cloud is there.
And the Cloud wouldn't be
real without our partners.
Please make sure,
as you are here,
to step by the partners'
booth and visit them,
because they are the ones that
take your opportunities, that
take your requirements,
and then make them
solutions on our Cloud platform.
I'm very happy to announce one
of our most prominent examples
on stage, a retailer.
One of the largest retailers
in Germany, needless to say,
one of the largest
retailers on the planet.
They serve businesses
and they serve consumers.
And they have a
clear vision on how
they help their customers in
their digital transformation.
Please welcome on stage, the CIO
and the chief solution officer
of Metro AG, Timo Salzsieder.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMO SALZSIEDER: So
good morning, everyone.
Happy to be here.
Thanks for the
invitation from Google.
Michael already mentioned
what we are doing,
and just to give you a bit of an
overview, you see on the slide
here--
because most of you should
be familiar with Metro.
You know these blue boxes.
If you've been around the
major cities in Germany,
you might also know Real
which is one of our brands.
But not a lot of people actually
know how big we really are.
So it's $36 billion
business, globally.
We are serving 35 countries
and our customers are mainly
out of the B2B space.
So we're talking about hotels,
restaurants, caterers, et
cetera, and we serve them
mostly with food but also
with non-food products.
It's a global
business, as I said.
We have 150,000
employees worldwide.
Within IT, we are 2 and 1/2
thousand people with a large
development unit, so we have
subsidiaries in Romania,
in India, in China,
obviously in Germany,
so Düsseldorf is
our headquarters,
which has opened recently
an office in Berlin,
also to attract
talents in that area.
And the funny
story was in Berlin
that we are on a campus with
a couple of other start-ups
there, and one of the guys
approached us and asked,
how is your funding doing?
And actually, they
did not obviously
know that we are quite big.
So we are doing well
regarding our funding.
So what are the challenges--
and Michael just mentioned,
we have obviously the issue
that we are pretty strong when
it comes to offline business.
So all our stores are going
really well, but as you know,
the food sector is
kind of slow, compared
to other areas like
clothing, books, consumer
electronics, et cetera.
And therefore, we
are moving obviously
into the digital space now,
so the digital transformation,
another buzzword used
within our organization.
And due to the fact that we
have these global operations,
we have obviously a couple
of massive challenges.
So scalability is,
for us, critical,
because we are present
in countries like India,
and just imagine that you
are running some campaigns
on mobile devices, send out
push messages, et cetera,
which obviously means
that millions of people
will approach all services.
So scalability is, for
us, really important.
The other issue is
performance, because we just
need to make sure
that our users are
getting excellent performance
out of our applications.
And security, you might
have seen in the news,
that Metro had also
some incidents regarding
WannaCry in Russia and Ukraine.
We handled it quite
easily, but at the end,
we are obviously attractive
for some of the hackers.
Therefore, security is
one of our top priorities.
The other thing I just mentioned
is the digital business.
And you see here a
couple of screenshots
about our actually offering
for the digital space
or classical web shops.
And we implement them,
basically completely
on our own solutions.
That means we are not using
any external software.
All of our offerings,
whether it's back
end solutions or internal
solutions, and also
web solutions, are implemented
with our own people.
And obviously, we
have challenges
like providing this
service globally.
You see a nice screenshot
here of one of the apps
we are running in China.
On the bottom right, you see
that's one of our flagship
stores in France.
We have these
self-standing devices,
so these little
devices on the left,
and there's a kiosk system
called heavy article kiosk
on the right side.
And you might wonder,
why are we having
a web shop within a store?
So the name says it already.
It's a heavy article kiosk.
So if you want to order, for
example, a beer barrel, which
is quite heavy, you
order it there directly.
You go to the cashier.
You identify yourself
with the Metro card,
and then there's a nice
gentleman from our staff,
and this gentleman is delivering
the beer barrel directly
to your car.
So this kind of service we are
offering in several stores.
We are mainly driven, obviously,
by innovation, innovation
about the internal services.
So you see logistics
is one of the topics.
The football fans
in the room might
identify one of our
customers at the top right.
So we are serving obviously
this football club,
mostly with beer and
currywurst, and sometimes
actually also with champagne,
if they play against Dortmund,
mainly.
And obviously, also try
to serve our customers
when it comes to
actually the touch
point with their customers.
So for example, within
the restaurants,
we will be providing
technology and service there.
And the most innovative
part is on the bottom left.
It's a self checkout service.
And just imagine you're
having a scanning device,
or it's a mobile app.
You're scan in the products,
you put it into the basket,
and then you drive this car
into this little device.
It's a scale.
So it weighs what's
in your cart.
The camera is on top of it.
It takes roughly
about 10 seconds.
And we're doing this currently
in Poland, 10 seconds,
and you're good to go.
No cashier, no payment,
no credit card.
It's in there.
And that just gives
you an impression
how innovative we
actually are doing.
So what's this partnership
with Google all about?
And obviously, we are
very excited about this,
otherwise I would
not be here on stage.
The scalability topic is
one of the major issues.
Coming back to the example
I mentioned earlier, we
are having these huge campaigns
running in these big countries,
and we are also
serving countries
like India and Pakistan,
just to bring you example.
And therefore, scalability
is a massive topic for us.
We are very happy about
the unmatched performance
of the Google network
because we serve, as I said,
customers globally,
and security is also
very well covered by Google.
And I know that Google
had a pretty hard time
with our legal people,
with our governance people,
and they did very well,
because at the end
we managed to finally sign
a contract with Google
and are now able to roll out
Google for our digital business
worldwide, and be using the
Google Cloud Platform to make
sure that our customers
get excellent service out
of our platform.
The other thing we
are doing with Google
is obviously engineering.
As I said, we have a huge
development community
with our own organization.
This is actually one of the
teams from us in Dusseldorf.
And we are just exchanging with
Google how methodology works.
For example, design
thinking is one
of the major topics we are
currently investing in,
but we are also leveraging
for our own applications
the APIs provided by Google.
So machine learning
is relevant for us.
We're doing a lot of natural
language processing, voice
recognition, image recognition.
So we are pretty
well on this route,
and therefore, using Google
as a technology partner
is really essential for us also
to drive our own applications.
So, and this is
obviously also something
that's relevant for us,
innovation drives us massively.
And we now have
obviously use cases
like you see here on the
screen, where we just
provide to our
customers, services
based on Google technology,
such as we mentioned,
there's a chef.
Obviously, dirty hands cannot
type on computer or any tablet,
so we offer them services
like, based on Google Home,
so that they can order
Metro products directly out
of the kitchen.
So these are the kind of
services we are providing.
So very happy to be
a part of Google.
Enjoy the collaboration
very much,
and thank you for
your attention.
And have a wonderful
Google Cloud Summit today.
[APPLAUSE]
MICHAEL KORBACHER: Thank
you very much, Timo.
We are very excited about
this partnership as well,
and we are very
excited to be working
with you on your vision.
I think we've got
to do something
about that soccer club.
That just came to me.
I don't think you've been
serving a lot of champagne
lately, you know?
I think that for those--
I think it's Cologne, right?
For those not familiar, I think
they're last in the league
right now, and they have a
little bit of catching up
to do, so maybe
there's some initiative
we have to think of there.
I'm excited to announce a
person next on the agenda who
is from our--
we call it the
office of the CTO.
And that's part
of the partnership
that we have with our clients.
Please let me welcome
on stage, Paul Strong.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
PAUL STRONG: Guten
morgen, munchen.
Wie gehts?
Gut?
Fantastic.
That's about the limit
of my German these days.
It's quite sad.
I was actually brought up
in a little village called
[GERMAN] on the [GERMAN].
But unfortunately, I moved back
to England when I was seven,
and I had no one
to speak German to.
So now I have this accent.
So firstly, welcome.
I think right now we live
in, quite possibly, one
of the most exciting
times that I can remember
in terms of the
evolution of technology
and how it is intersecting
with business and with life.
I think we saw with
the example of Metro,
there is a real
transformation taking place.
This is not just about
technology allowing
you to do things faster,
cheaper, and more
reliably than you could before.
This is not about
incremental change.
Absolutely, you
can use technology
to make it cheaper,
faster, and more reliable,
but technology today is being
used to do things differently,
fundamentally differently.
And this is what digital
transformation is all about.
This is not about
business as usual.
government as usual.
This is about doing
things differently.
It's about thinking
about things differently.
Every company in this world
becomes a technology business.
It's about writing software.
It's about getting intimacy
and insight into your customers
and the world around you.
This is what the digital
transformation is all about.
And it's driven by a set
of technology trends.
Many of them have been
evolving over many years,
but they've all come together
at this point in time
to enable true
transformation and change.
If you think about Cloud--
for me, Cloud is
not a destination.
Cloud is a vehicle that takes us
on this digital transformation
journey.
Cloud-- with the
first time with Cloud,
you can get technology, and
particularly the technology
that doesn't differentiate
you, as a commodity.
In the past you had
to buy software.
You had to buy the
hardware to run it on.
You had to buy the people
to run the software
and run the hardware.
Now you can make it
someone else's problem
so that you can focus on
what differentiates you, what
makes you more competitive.
This is what Cloud allows.
With mobility, you can now
engage with anyone anywhere.
You know, you can make good
guesses as to what they're
doing, what they're
doing in their lives,
you're getting intimacy.
And from that intimacy, you can
get insight and understanding
so that you can deliver
better services,
whether that's monetizing ads
or whether it's allowing people
to do amazing things.
You see governments who put
applications on phones so
that their customers,
their citizens,
can take photographs of potholes
in the road in Malaysia,
and they automatically
end up on a list
of things to be done by
the Ministry of Transport.
Mobility is changing everything.
Social is changing everything.
The interaction model, the way
people engage with each other,
is shifting and changing.
In some ways we talk a
lot about globalization,
and we think about it
in terms of industry,
but there's a globalization
of friendships.
My daughter, well, one of
my four daughters, is 25.
She's from England.
She met friends online.
She went partying with many
of them, actually in Poland,
and now she's moved
to Australia, where
a whole bunch of them live.
But this whole-- the way people
talk to each other, the way
people engage, the way people
share information and trends
are driven, is fundamentally
shifting and changing.
IoT gives that same
connection that you
see with social and mobile,
but not with people,
but with machines.
I'm connected.
I'm a cyborg.
Did you know that?
I happen to be diabetic, and I
have a constant flow glucometer
plumbed into my arm.
That allows my wife, 5,000
miles away in the United States,
to know that I am healthy.
And I can monitor my 8-year-old
daughter, who is also diabetic.
And if my wife is asleep
and my daughter goes low,
I can give her a
call and wake her up
so that there
isn't an emergency.
This connectedness
is allowing us
to get more data and insight.
And all of that, big data.
The job of technologists is
to turn that data into insight
and understanding,
and then act on it,
to be able to
engage, again, back
through the internet of
things or with mobile.
This intersection of all
of these technologies
is profoundly changing
everything we do in life,
and it says that every
organization and every business
today is a technology business.
Your success will be defined
by how you use and consume
technology, and your
failure, or your epitaph
on your gravestone,
will be how you
didn't, if you don't
take advantage of it.
What we see happening
with this technology
is technology is being used.
It is being used to
undermine the assumptions,
the foundations, that you
build business models on.
I'll give you a
couple of examples.
The first one is a
fairly famous one.
Most of you will be
familiar with the stories
of ride sharing and
things like Uber and Lyft.
What's interesting here is the
story of how it came about.
So taxis, you know, it's an
old established business.
And there's certain barriers
to entry to the market place.
If you want to be
a taxi driver, you
have to learn your
way around cities
because driving with a map in
your lap is kind of dangerous.
And you kind of want
to know that you
can trust the taxi driver.
So in London, they have a
thing called the Knowledge,
and you spend three
years studying
all the streets and the
landmarks around London.
And it's quite
interesting, actually.
So these taxi drivers-- all
this memorization and recall
actually turns
them into mutants.
So it turns out that when
you memorize things so much,
it actually makes a
part of your brain
bigger, physically bigger.
So the Darwin in
me says that if we
look at taxi drivers
for long enough,
they'll end up with
these enormous heads,
just like those aliens that you
see in 1950s science fiction
movies.
The point is that these
businesses in the underlying
assumptions were predicated on
teaching drivers and validating
them through licensing.
Now, with a mobile device,
it has GPS, it has voice,
it has maps, it can
tell you where to go.
You can summon your ride,
you can see where it is,
you can give feedback at the
end so that you get a better
idea of the reputation of
the driver than you ever,
ever could before.
This is a fundamental shift.
This is technology disrupting
established businesses.
If you think of the spare parts
business and the logistics,
3D printing means you don't
need warehouses full of spares
anymore.
You can print them on demand
with 3D printers and CNC
machines at the edge.
This disruption is
coming to all of us
where technology is
being used and it says,
is that assumption that your
model is built on valid anymore
in the face of technology?
And when it isn't,
then there's risk,
because the small and
nimble, with nothing to lose,
have access to the same
technologies as the largest
businesses in the world.
And that is because of Cloud.
So when we think about
the journey going forward,
the question is, what
does it look like?
What are the steps?
We put it down into
four key areas.
The first, optimize.
Get out of the
business of delivering
IT that doesn't
differentiate you,
and make it someone
else's problem.
Make it Google's
problem, because what
doesn't differentiate you
does differentiate us.
So that you can focus
on collaboration,
driving teams to work together
to be more productive and more
effective, and through
that collaboration,
drive innovation.
And then to accelerate
your business,
to be able to focus
on the technology that
enables insight and
engagement to actually drive
new value, new services,
and to take them to market.
And then in doing all of that,
you need the right partner.
We believe we are
that partner to help
you take that digital
transformation journey.
Let's quickly talk
about optimize
and what's happening
in that space.
For us, Google Cloud
is a full suite
of products going from
the low level of offering
compute network and
storage all the way up
to work collaboration
suites like G Suite.
When we talk to our customers,
there's a set of drivers
that we see.
Reliability, security,
and so forth.
It's the classic list that IT
want out of infrastructure.
Google, what doesn't
differentiate you,
you want to get us
infrastructure as a service.
I say is infrastructure is
a differentiator for us.
We believe, and our businesses,
all of those billion user
businesses, have driven us to
deliver better infrastructure,
more scalable.
In fact, we build
our own servers.
If we sold servers,
we'd probably
be the world's third or
fourth largest server vendor,
but we don't sell any.
They're all built and
customized for Google
so that we can deliver services
that are more reliable,
that are faster, and cheaper
than we could in any other way.
And we were driven to do that by
the growth of our own business.
And the opportunity for you
is to take advantage of that.
It's also about managing
things in a different way.
With site reliability,
engineering
is about taking us to a
place when we build out
infrastructure in
this new world,
we think differently
about availability.
It's all about resilience
and reliability,
and it's baking it into
everything that we do.
The apps in this
new world assume
the infrastructure breaks.
So you have to build and
design them differently,
and you have to manage
them differently,
and we wrote the
book on it, something
we shared with the world.
And I encourage all
of you to actually
get the site reliability
engineering book
and to have a read and learn
how Google has figured out
at least how to deliver
at extreme scale
and with great reliability.
I always say one of the amazing
things about Google that you
can learn is we can afford
to make the mistakes that you
can't.
We've been very lucky.
We have a very
successful business.
And we've been
able to experiment
and learn the lessons
that otherwise
would be very expensive.
In terms of delivering
performance,
we have something rather unique.
Google actually has a navy.
I bet you didn't
know that, right?
We actually have ships.
And what those ships do is they
lay cables under the ocean.
One of our main
differentiators is actually
by having our own physical
network with the fibers that we
own ourselves going
across the globe,
we are in a position to make
your applications perform
and be more reliable than
in any other infrastructure.
You don't have to
worry about talking
with Telco providers
for WAN connections
because we can
give you very, very
fat, fast, low latency
pipes across the world,
so that when you build
applications and run them
on Google Cloud, they
can talk to each other
and get very, very low latency.
And in fact, today, something
like 40% of the total world's
internet traffic goes across
Google's own private network.
This is pretty insane.
By the way, when
I joined Google,
I was like, insane engineering.
Crazy numbers.
We build a lot of our
own networking kit.
To allow our customers to
take advantage of this,
we also now have direct
connection capabilities
around the world so that you can
place your servers so that they
don't have the
internet between them
and your services that
sit inside Google's Cloud.
And we value the set of regions.
We talked earlier about moving
into Germany and Frankfurt,
and we're moving into other
areas around the world,
expanding very, very fast.
All of this is about giving
you unrivaled performance
and scale.
In fact, our investment
in delivering all of this
is somewhere in the
region of $30 billion
in terms of a trailing,
three year, CapEx investment.
This is so that you don't
have to make that investment.
We invest in the infrastructure
scalable, resilient,
so that you don't have to do it.
And we can deliver
it in a way that
is very cost effective, and very
green, and very sustainable.
We use technologies like
machine learning and AI
to actually drive down
the energy consumption
of our own data centers.
Everything you see in the
services we offer outside we
use inside, to enable Google
to scale and be reliable.
And this is reflected in
our performance numbers.
You will generally see that
Google is there or thereabouts
in terms of providing the
highest performing as well
as extremely reliable and
cost effective services.
Finally, I'd like to
briefly talk about security
because ultimately, what we
hear from our customers is
all of this is great, but
without security, who really
gives a damn about all of this.
Right?
It's just table stakes.
At Google, it's everything
that we think about.
Our entire stack is
optimized for security.
We customize, we build
our own motherboards,
we build our own chipsets, we
build our own operating systems
so they can be
efficient, but also,
so that we can get rid of all
of the unnecessary components
so that people can't attack them
and they can't be compromised.
So we end up with a
very, very secure stack.
We even have our own
silicon, our own chips,
that we put in our devices
to allow us to understand
their entire history.
In doing all of
this, that security
also results in compliance.
So with Google Cloud,
when we satisfy
some criteria in terms of
compliance, for example,
HIPAA in the United
States, or whatever,
it doesn't apply to some
subset of Google Cloud.
It's all of Google Cloud.
And so all of Google Cloud
is essentially homogeneous.
It looks the same.
If it's qualified for some
criteria, then all of it is.
And as Michael said earlier,
part of that compliance story
is also around GDPR.
And, you know, when it comes
to the fore in March next year,
we're working very hard,
both with our customers
and internally, to make
sure all of us are ready.
A couple of quick areas
around security innovation.
The first is
Identity Aware Proxy.
Now, why would you
care about this?
Well, Google's kind
of interesting.
When I would work at Google,
when I joined Google,
we actually don't
use VPNs to connect
into Google infrastructure.
We actually assume we
have a zero trust model,
and what we want is fine grained
access to our applications
and services inside Google.
So what we do is we actually do
everything through a browser.
It doesn't matter whether
we are on Google's Wi-Fi
or outside on the internet.
And this actually uses a
service, called the Identity
Aware Proxy, that allows
us to get inside Google's
infrastructure and to work
with all the applications
and services we need
to, but with very
fine grained security.
And this we now offer as a
service for our customers.
Secondly, another
area of innovation
is the data loss prevention
API, which is really
around focusing
on managing data,
making sure that only
the right people can
get at the right data,
and getting rid of data,
or getting it out of
sight, for the people who
shouldn't be at it.
So what I'd like to do now
is to have a demonstration,
and we'll talk about DLP.
And to do that, please join
me in welcoming to the stage
Lee Boonstra.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
LEE BOONSTRA: Thank you, Bob.
Yes, like Paul
already mentioned,
now with the GDPR
coming next year,
we certainly need to be aware
of what's in our database,
if it's sensitive data, our
personal data in our datasets.
As a developer, I'm
always worried about that,
so luckily, we now have the DLP
API, data loss prevention API,
which can help you with that.
And the way how it works
is you pass in a text,
and then as a second argument,
you specify some fields
where you want to scan form.
And these fields can be passport
number, credit card number,
phone number, and then
you can scan your dataset,
whether you're connected to
your data pool as a batch
or as a call in real
time, and you get back
the data that is sensitive.
And you can even flag it.
You can even mask it.
To show that, I'd like
to show you a demo.
And I thought I'd
like to create or take
a kind of real live demo
here, like a chat application.
And this is just a
fictional company, right?
It's called Acme
customer support.
And they sell anvils, you know?
Like these hammers
that they sell
in the World of
Warcraft or Skyrim.
And what's happening here
is like in the check books,
Angela is complaining that
the product doesn't work
and the employee asks, OK, well,
what is your contact number?
And then here's the thing.
This is always
what customers do.
When there is an
input field, they just
enter everything they have.
Like, oh, here, this
is my phone number.
This is my name.
This is my last name.
Here's my credit card number.
Here is my passport.
And then at that moment, yeah,
now that's in our dataset.
Now that can be in our database.
But luckily, we
implemented a DLP API here.
So what I'm doing here
is when I enter chat,
there it goes, you
see, it makes a call.
And immediately, it starts
flagging the sensitive data
out.
So this data won't be stored.
And this chat application
is just a nice UI,
but what you can see
here is the actual call
that's been made returns JSON.
And that's what you--
yeah.
This is how the API
looks like, and this
is what you can implement.
So that's kind of cool.
Let's have another example here.
And for this example, I
like to make use of a camera
that I have here on stage.
And I took here a passport,
a German passport,
and a German bank card.
And we're going to
make a picture of it
and see if we, in real time,
can mask the sensitive data.
Now in this demo,
just to show you
that it works with these field
names, this array of fields
that you pass in, I
can show you the fields
that we're, in this
case, scanning for.
So I'm looking here
for credit card number,
driving license numbers,
faces, pass photo.
But also, specific for Germany,
there is a passport field.
And we have it for all
kinds of countries.
So for example, for
the Netherlands,
we have a BSN
number, which is what
we put in a Dutch passport.
Right?
So now let's make a picture
and see what happens here.
There you go.
Now, and before you
guys think, like, oh,
this is probably
all scripted, I'd
like to welcome
Paul back on stage
and we can make a selfie here.
PAUL STRONG: I like that.
LEE BOONSTRA: Yes,
I like that, too.
PAUL STRONG: A selfie.
I like being
redacted on selfies.
Is this going to do it for me?
LEE BOONSTRA: All right.
Hey.
PAUL STRONG: Yay.
LEE BOONSTRA: Thank you.
PAUL STRONG: Thank
you very much, Lee.
[APPLAUSE]
So I think it's
a very cool demo.
But what it really
shows is the value.
As we externalize
sets of services
and complicated technologies
like machine learning,
you are able to make use of
those, trivially and simply.
Some of these in applications
and services you see
built in the demos.
They can be built very
rapidly and very quickly,
and you can get
value out of them.
And this security
that we talked about,
it's in depth in
everything we do,
from the client, and
Chrome, and Android,
all the way through to
GCP at the back end.
What I'd like to do now,
I think you've already
heard from Metro,
and I think it's
great to hear the real stories
of people's transformation.
At this point, I'd like
to welcome to the stage
another customer to share
some time with you, talking
about how Google
Cloud has helped
them transform
their organization
and their business.
And to do that,
welcome to the stage,
from Deutsche Boerse,
Thomas Curran.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
THOMAS CURRAN: Paul.
Thank you.
So hello, good morning.
Deutsche Boerse.
Probably none of you
really know much about it,
but I'll give you a few things.
One is if we had Formula
One of marketplaces,
we'd be racing in it.
We do about 200 million
contracts a month
in marketplace transactions.
If we were a bank, we'd
also be in the big boys.
We have about 13.1 trillion
assets under management.
So we have the very fast
stuff and the very big stuff,
and in the middle, we have
quite a lot of challenges,
dealing with a very
complex set of businesses.
Security was just mentioned.
I think if anyone in the room
can imagine themselves building
an infrastructure that's more
secure than Google, good luck.
I'm a Google Cloud junkie,
and one of the reasons
is because I believe it's the
most secure infrastructure you
can buy anywhere.
That's very important for our
business because of the size,
but it's also very important
because security today is not
a one way street.
It's something that you have to
be able to count on over time.
And if you go and talk to Google
and look at their security
infrastructure, you'll see why.
The best minds.
The best technology.
Compliance, we obviously have
a lot of rules in our business,
and implementing those
rules and doing it
over time with a trusted
partner is very important.
But also, we understand
flexibility is also an issue.
Over time, compliance changes
because of new regulations
and new things that happen
in markets, new instruments,
disasters, 2008, so compliance
is a very big issue,
and we need a partner
to deal with that.
And by the way, two years ago,
when I brought up Google Cloud,
I think it's fair to say people
laughed me out of the room.
They said that Google doesn't
understand this business.
But they do.
Google is not the only
Cloud provider that we use.
The reason for that
is we also need
to have flexibility in the
way we deliver services.
And we develop software
on multiple platforms,
so Google gives us a
lot of capabilities
to move between those
Cloud platforms,
and in particular,
what's very important
is some of the new
things that were
mentioned here, the compute
platform, Kubernetes,
in particular.
So we have these
things that give us
multi Cloud
capabilities, and that's
very important for our business.
Why is that important?
What are we doing?
We're building a
global platform.
Deutsche Boerse is in 27
countries across the world,
mostly in Europe, but also in
the United States and Asia.
And to serve customers
in those countries,
we need a scalable
and resilient platform
to deliver our
business services.
On top of that, we're building
new business, business
that relies on a Cloud
infrastructure for real time
smart data and analytics.
Those analytics are built
on very new technologies
that we deliver in the
Cloud, and we deliver them
via an API platform.
And the ecosystem of
trusted Fintech companies
that we've been able to
sign up and work with,
and it's a growing.
And if you're in Fintech,
please talk to me about it.
All of that is new,
and as we already
heard today multiple times,
the world is being digital.
Digitization is important.
And in our business, developing
new digital business models
and delivering new
digital products
is very, very important
to growing the business.
Here's one example.
It's very concrete.
We have a big, giant pipeline
of real time data coming out
of our trading
infrastructure, again,
200 million contracts a month.
Those are not just
for derivatives.
They're cash, they're
foreign exchange,
there's reference data.
By the way, we run also
the largest energy trading
infrastructure in Europe.
We use different
technology standards.
For instance, Pub/Sub
some from Google,
we use PCAP, which is a
network standard, we use CSV,
we use XML, we use JSON.
We put all of those things
in different formats
into a data link on
Google Cloud Storage.
That's very important
because again, in the past,
flexibility was not a given.
You had to structure
information to store it
in large infrastructures.
Today, that's changed a lot.
That's changed a lot because
you have new technologies that
let you then transform
that information, big data,
BigQuery, TensorFlow,
machine learning.
To operate in Google Cloud,
we use a very great invention
from Google, by the
way, called Go Language.
If any of you have ever
tried it, I suggest it.
We use it because
Google learned,
as we learned, that managing
large complex infrastructures,
you need to have
speed and reliability.
So we're building
our bots in Go.
We're building data
marts then in Bigtable.
And then we're providing
those to customers
via our digital business
platform, which is, guess what?
Also written in Go and has
APIs that then customers,
partners, academia, people
we never met before,
can now consume data from
Deutsche Boerse group,
in particular market data,
from this public dataset
based on BigQuery.
We're doing all that
because, again, it's not only
I'm a Google Cloud junkie.
We're doing it because we
see a growing and emerging
new kind of computing
infrastructure that we believe
will deliver better results,
will deliver better security,
and over time, gives us
the reliability we need
to build a global
infrastructure that
will help our business grow.
Thank you, Google,
for having us.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
PAUL STRONG: Thank
you so much, Thomas.
THOMAS CURRAN: You're
welcome, thanks.
PAUL STRONG: Really
appreciate it,
and we really appreciate
your partnership.
So this morning we've talked--
had customer
examples, we've talked
a lot about digital
transformation,
the stages of the journey,
the notion of optimize.
Get out of the
business of the IT
that doesn't differentiate you.
Next, we're actually going
to explore collaboration,
he says, if the
slide will come up.
So optimize.
Get out of the
business of delivering
the IT that doesn't
differentiate,
and focus on what
does differentiate.
And then what you
really need to do
is to drive productivity
and the environment that
drives innovation.
That's all about collaboration.
And to spend some time
talking to you about that
and sharing where we
are going at Google,
and how you can take
advantage of our work,
please welcome to the
stage, Bill Hippenmeyer.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Thank you, sir.
BILL HIPPENMEYER: Good morning.
Great to be here.
So you might ask yourself,
where does collaboration
fit into the power of the Cloud?
We could talk about
AI, and we could
talk about transformation
services, infrastructure
capabilities, and
all the things that
are involved in being
able to take workloads
from your systems
and your environment,
and take advantage
of the leverage
the network that we provide
in all those things.
Why collaboration?
Where does collaboration fit in?
It is our belief at Google that
collaboration is the beginning
of this transformation process.
If you think about
it, transformation
is the end result of a big idea.
Where do big ideas come?
They come from the
creative juices and forces
that are happening
within your organization.
Creativity is all about what?
Creativity begins
with engagement.
Engagement is when one,
two, three, and more people
gather together and they
begin to synthesize new ideas.
One person has a concept,
a problem, a solution,
some thoughts about
something, but then that's
immediately impacted by
the people and organization
around them.
And ideas come from everywhere.
They come from the top
of the organization
where we're doing strategy
and thinking out forward.
They come from the grass
roots of the organization
where in retail stores,
in manufacturing plants,
and across the business,
people are coming up
with new ideas, new approaches,
and new ways to solve problems.
That has to be facilitated
with an infrastructure.
In today's world, I'm
going to state the obvious.
You're going to say,
Bill, we get it.
Right?
Things are moving faster.
If you look at the innovation
cycles in today's world,
if you examine the product
lifecycle and the ability
to bring new products
to market, you no longer
have 20 years to bring
a new BMW to market.
You no longer have 20 years to
reconstruct new life science
approaches, or think about
new transportation logistics
solutions, or to rethink
digital communications
across the globe.
What you must do is you
must shrink that lifecycle.
You must accelerate ideation.
And the only way to
do that, we believe,
is to be equipped with a
proper set of tools to do so.
The Google Suite that
we have constructed,
and the tools that we
would invite you to use,
are built around this ability
to gather people together
in real time to
collaborate to come up
with the big idea,
which is going
to lead to the transformation
that you're looking to do.
So we have a set of tools that
allow you to create and to rise
that level of creation
instead of being
an individual activity, but to
make it a group activity where
you're working in real time.
We provide tools that
allow you to connect.
Connect in real
time, exchange ideas,
and be able to
riff off each other
and synthesize new
thoughts in new areas.
We do that with the ability
to quickly search and access
content in one place,
held in Google Drive,
and then of course
we have to give you
the control, the security,
the compliance, the DLP
capabilities, to be able
to protect that content so
that you can be compliant
with things like GDPR.
And when you do it,
there's an impact.
PWC adopted the
Google Apps or G Suite
platform several years ago.
They rolled it out worldwide,
and they saw a dramatic impact
in terms of their productivity.
If you think about the
world that they live in,
their consultants are working
every day, both internally
and externally,
to be able to try
to advise on financial issues,
tax issues, and a variety
of other consulting areas.
What they have found
is that by being
able to reduce the
amount of travel
they have through
Google Hangouts
and being able to
connect real time,
through collaborative
document editing
and inviting both the
customer and the suppliers
that they're involved with
into the conversation,
they're finding that they're
able to get things done faster.
And the ability to be able
to connect in real time,
those things have
led to real savings.
In a study that they
did, they came back
and said that on
average, they are
saving nine hours per
week per employee,
and they have a
lot of employees.
That's real numbers.
And the financial people
love the impact of that.
But why can't we
just use the tools
we've been using for years
to accomplish the same thing?
Our argument and
our platform says
that the way of collaboration
that our competitors are
offering is really an old
school style of methods.
They haven't really
changed, fundamentally,
the way you work.
In fact, I often talk to
C level executives that
have adopted the
competitor platform,
and I've asked them
this one question.
What are you doing
different today
now that you've adopted the
latest from your competitor,
and how has that transformed
the way you work, and how has
that accelerated your
ideation platform?
And in every case,
they say, well,
Bill, that's not
what we were about.
We wanted to eliminate the
impact of change management
on our organization.
We didn't really want
to change anything.
We liked the way
we were working.
And I'm like, really?
Is that what you want to do?
You want to just
work the way you've
been working for 20 years,
where an individual creates
a document, or a spreadsheet,
or a presentation,
and then they send
it out in email
as an attachment as
a way to collaborate
and be able to exchange ideas?
If you were going to come up
with the top 10 vacation list
ideas in a matter of minutes,
would you get into a document
and list the top 10
and then send it out
to 10 of your colleagues
and wait for them to reply?
No.
You would actively engage with
them in real time, most likely
in a conference room
or in a Google Doc,
and say, let's come up
with the top 10 quickly.
And when everybody is
typing at the same time
and they're all interacting in a
collaborative way, what happens
is you begin to raise
the ideas quickly.
You begin to collaborate and
have visual inspection of what
other people are doing.
And now what you
can do is you can
avoid the need to replicate
what Greg has put down.
So Greg and I are collaborating.
Tom and I are collaborating.
Alexander and I
are collaborating.
And I can quickly see they
don't like Cancun, Mexico.
They prefer Nice or Malaga
Spain to be able to do vacation.
That's their preference.
They're Europeans, and I
don't have that experience.
Now, I do live in
London now, which
has been a really eye
opening experience
and I'm really enjoying it.
All right.
And then the most
important thing
that I really love
about the Suite
is the ability to
connect in real time.
The reality is
that we don't have
to wait for the Thursday
afternoon meeting that's
scheduled for one hour because
all meetings must go an hour.
That's just the
rule of meetings.
Right?
That's not the case.
When I can have an
idea or an inspiration
and I can literally reach
out to Joe and Karen and say,
can you join me on a
Hangout for five minutes
and let's walk through
this concept and this idea.
And when I ping them and they
come back to me and they say,
yep, I'm available, and
we get on a Hangout,
in five or 10 minutes, we can
move the idea forward in a way
that a meeting on Thursday
afternoon at 3 o'clock
would not do.
So the ability to
instantaneously reach out,
click of a button, and
connect in real time
is a powerful capability.
And that's what we're doing.
And then lastly,
and you're going
to hear a lot more about
this, is the application
of artificial intelligence
to this environment.
AI, in its simplest
form, is really
about observing
patterns and then
being able to recognize the
outcomes that are associated
those patterns, and then
being able to do something
that's predictive and being
able to actually look forward.
I think of it like this.
If I asked you to be a diving
judge at the next Olympics,
how qualified are you today?
Probably not very
well qualified.
I'm not.
But if you sat with a
Olympic judge expert
and watched 100 dives, you'd
be a little bit better.
What if you watched 1,000 dives?
10,000 dives?
100,000 dives?
A million dives?
We are literally taking samples
from a billion people that
are simultaneously
using our products,
and we're able to look
at what they're doing
and predict what's next.
And one of the great
examples of that
is expanded upon in
Explore in Sheets.
If you regularly get
a dataset, maybe it's
a point of sale data,
and you're trying
to ask a simple question
like, OK, Google.
Show me the highest
profit product that
was sold during the months
of September, October,
and November across the
different states in Germany,
and illustrate--
raise to the top
the most productive
or the best margin product
during that period.
You don't want to have to write
the formula that does that.
But Google has been watching
the way experts analyze data.
And from thousands and
millions of examples,
they can actually-- we can
actually predict what's next
and offer some insight,
immediately, when you open up.
So all you have to do is
hit the Explore button,
and now I have a set of
graphs, and charts, and pivots,
that are already available
to me to be able to examine.
And I can do that without having
to do any work whatsoever,
and then I can start
to ask questions,
and Google will actually
write the formula for you.
So we're doing a
lot of work in AI,
and that's only one
example of many,
in terms of what
we're doing to be
able to app apply
artificial intelligence
and machine learning to your
work as you collaborate.
So let's not just
take my word for it.
But what I'd like to
do is invite a customer
to come up and talk a little
bit about what they're doing
in the application at G Suite.
So I'm happy to invite
Alex Pollmann from Vismon
to come and share
his experience.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALEXANDER POLLMANN:
So yeah, welcome.
Good morning from my side.
I'm really happy, proud
to tell you, that we
have gone Google this year.
And we have gone G Suite.
It's a digital transformation
at Vismon with G Suite.
Vismon is a traditional
family owned business,
and we are producing
heating boilers,
cooling systems, and also
some industrial systems.
Our revenue is about
2.2 billion euros,
and we have 12,000 employees
all over the world.
So we started our digital
transformation around 2015
because we saw their new
business models came up,
new competitors, also
company of alphabet,
Nest I have also on my slides.
They came up, and
they are taking
our core business, and also our
thoughts about new businesses.
So what we have done, we
have spread out a strategy
for our digital transformation.
And there was a project
called the future workplace.
So the future workplace
is more about--
at the very beginning, it's more
about evaluation of a platform
solution.
So we came from an IBM
Notes infrastructure.
We have run IBM Notes
for these 22 years,
and you know it is a big
growing infrastructure.
So our priorities also
lay on the usability.
Because if you want
to use your software
and you'll also want
to use a user software,
you have to get them
on an easy software.
Functionality was
also an [INAUDIBLE]..
Also, the IT security.
All of you heard about the
security layer of Google.
This is maybe also one of the
reasons why we choose Google
because we think it is the most
secure platform for us to use.
So the integration part,
and also the costs,
were also prioritized
in the evaluation.
At the end, we decided
to move to G Suite
and we are really happy.
We have now workplace
that is easily
accessible on any device,
at any place, at any time.
Paul mentioned,
our people should
engage any time, any place.
They should easily get together.
They should create ideas.
We have now more flexibility,
more security, more
a team collaboration,
and also more
transparency at the same costs.
So our main
achievements, like, we
have started the global rollout
for G Suite this year, in June.
And we have an average
1,500 people each month
coming to G Suite.
We have migrated them.
15% of our users are using
bring your own device services.
Just imagine if,
like, 1,200 people
spent 10 minutes each
day in their private life
with their work environment.
That are, like, 200 hours a
day your company will save.
1.7 million emails doesn't
need to be archived anymore.
In IBM Notes, we had
just 100 megabyte space
left in your email.
No other storage is unlimited.
It's great.
And everyone uses two
factor identification.
So everyone can reach his
work benefits from everywhere.
And he just needs to get
his smartphone [INAUDIBLE]
and say, yes, I am.
So 4,500 Google Meets
are done each month.
So if you've heard,
it's just six months ago
we started the rollout, and it's
pretty increasing, this number.
Also, it's, like, 4,500.
If you think for 4,500, if
for one Google Meet of 100
is just a business trip,
you can save as a company.
You will save around 45 to 50
business trips every month,
and your people could engage
everywhere, everywhere,
at any time.
So the last part is all
about collaboration.
We don't send any
documents anymore.
It's all, like, we share
it, and collaborate in one
document and all this stuff.
I really like it.
And I really would
like to thank all
of my team colleagues,
and also our partner,
[INAUDIBLE],, for
the great support
we had during the migration.
But I'm pretty sure
that this is just
the beginning of a big change
at our future workplace.
And I'm really looking forward
to all the new cool stuff
that will come from
Google in the future.
Thank you, guys.
[APPLAUSE]
BILL HIPPENMEYER: Thank
you, Alex, for sharing.
I really appreciate that.
So we've talked about
optimize, about leveraging
the power of Google
infrastructure, network,
and data center services.
Hopefully you've
got some insight
into why collaboration
is so important to us.
What I'd like to
do next is take you
to the next level,
which is accelerate.
In acceleration, it's really
about learning and growing,
and harnessing the power of
big data, machine learning,
and technologies like
that, that will really
help you be able to move
faster, and to move better.
So with that, I'd like
to introduce my friend
and colleague, Greg
DeMichillie, who's
going to talk a little
bit about accelerate.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
GREG DEMICHILLIE:
Thanks, everyone.
I'm really excited to talk
about this section of the talk
because, as Paul said, going
into Cloud to just shift
a little bit of CapEx to
OpEx or save 5 or 10%,
really misses the opportunity
that it provides you.
The opportunity to
not just save money,
not just to affect your
cost side of the business,
but to drive new business.
And the best way
to think about that
is to think about
it in terms of,
how do you get
value out of data?
Think about it.
As companies, we have
become digital pack rats.
We store ever increasing
amounts of data.
By some estimates, we'll have
163 zettabytes of data per year
by 2025.
I had to Google what a
zettabyte is, by the way.
Just in case you
don't know, I believe
it's a trillion gigabytes.
And why is it that
we're doing that?
The Cloud has made it possible.
To store a petabyte
of data 10 years ago,
you had to get a
robotic tape archive.
You had to spend millions of
dollars on special machinery.
Now, for a penny a
gigabyte a month,
you can store every bit
of data from your factory,
or your business, or
your retail operation.
So the problem has
shifted from, how
do I store that data, to how
do I find the needle of value
in that haystack of data?
Now the way this works for
most of us today is big data.
Right?
That's the answer.
Big data.
And we know something
about that at Google,
because most of what
is in big data today
dates to research papers that
Google published 10 years ago.
Big data is built on
a foundation of work
that we did within Google.
And we went through
this pattern which
is we build these
big data systems,
we run them in production, the
data grows by a factor of 10,
we have to re-architect
the storage system,
and the result is, if
you look at most data
big data projects within
enterprises today,
they're not achieving the
results that they promised.
And why is it?
It's because if you look
at where you actually
spend your dollars
and your time,
it's not on getting insights.
You spend way too much time on
building maintenance, logging,
backup, disaster
recovery, oh no, the data
is 10 times as big, let me
rebuild my sharding system.
Nobody enjoys doing that, yet
we do it time and time again.
You spend too much time
taking care of the machinery,
and not enough time actually
understanding the data.
And again, we know this
is the case because we
went through this at Google.
We went through this
exact same pattern.
We built data systems, we
thought they were great,
the data got too big,
we had to rebuild them,
and we realized we had
to have a better way.
We had to have a different
way to think about big data.
So we set about building out
an entirely new set of data
and analytics products around
the simple idea of reversing
this ratio, of inverting the
amount of time you spent taking
care of the system
and the amount of time
you actually spent
getting Insights.
So across our entire
data portfolio,
you will see products built
natively for the Cloud
where all of the work of
scaling, and infrastructure,
and management, and even DBA,
is taken care of for you.
And we've also gone
one step further,
because we also realized at
Google, that traditional batch
analytics aren't good enough.
The days when you could have a
weekly report of your business
and call that acceptable,
if you're a retailer,
you want to know
what's happening today,
not what happened two weeks ago.
If you're a
manufacturer, you want
to know that you're
having production problems
today, not on a quarterly
report when it's too late
to do anything about it.
So we built our systems
around the notion
that batch and streaming
are the same thing.
That it should be as easy
to get real time insights
as it is to get a daily, or
weekly, or quarterly business
report.
And so when you look across
our entire data portfolio,
whether it's BigQuery, which
is a data and analytics
warehouse in the
Cloud-- literally,
upload a petabyte of
data, write a SQL query.
Done.
No DBA, no sharding,
nothing to set up.
Or Dataproc, which lets you take
your existing Hadoop clusters,
bring them in the
Cloud, and get out
of the business of managing
the Hadoop infrastructure.
Or Pub/Sub and Dataflow,
which you heard about
from our customers, using that
to transform the way you ingest
data in real time.
What all these products
have in common is
they get you out of the drudgery
of maintaining the machinery.
And they let you
focus on the fun part.
I know of no data
analytics professional
who got into it because they
liked writing sharding systems.
Do what's the fun
part, the understanding
the analytics of data.
And we see this having
an impact on customers.
Spotify, when they
joined Google,
if you talk to their
execs, they will tell you,
the number one reason that
they wanted to use Google
was to give them a
competitive advantage in data.
Think about it.
Every time you skip a
song, or you play a song,
or use search for a
song in Spotify, that's
data that helps them predict
that next perfect music
for you.
Or in the banking
industry, Lloyd's,
where they say they
literally went from 96 hours
to 30 minutes in
terms of their ability
to go from an event
happening in the market
to them being able to make
a decision based on that.
Now, what's the
next step of this?
Sure, we can build
data warehouses.
You've heard mentioned
several times
this notion of machine learning
and artificial intelligence.
And we really think
that is the next step.
It's the next evolution in
how you do data analytics.
And to prove just how
much we believe in it,
our CEO, Sundar Pichai,
has said that this
is a core transformative
way where we're
rethinking everything
we're doing
and that is literally
true at Google.
There is not a project or
a product inside Google
that isn't being
rethought in terms
of machine learning and
artificial intelligence.
If you think about
the consumer side,
every way that you interact with
Google now has an AI or machine
learning component,
whether it's your Android
smartphone and the way it
does speech recognition
or auto correction.
Or how many of you
have used Google Photos
and typed birthday
party clown and found
a picture from three years ago
of your child's birthday party
when you had a clown come in?
Or when you've used Gmail,
as Bill talked about,
where you've had an
automatic reply generated.
All of these are
built on the notion
of artificial intelligence
and machine learning.
Now it's reasonable to ask, why?
I mean, Google has
smart programmers.
Couldn't we have just done this
ourselves without using ML?
And I think it's important
to think about why
ML was so transformative.
ML lets us solve problems that
we don't know how to solve.
Think about when you
learned your first language.
Unless you have fairly
unusual parents,
I don't think they handed you a
grammar book and a dictionary.
But that's what we
do as programmers.
We teach our computers with
grammar books and dictionaries.
You learned your first
language by being
exposed to it, by example.
Your family had a dog.
Your parents said dog.
You saw the dog.
Literally, the
chemistry in your brain
changed, and you learned
that that piece--
that animal was a dog.
ML allows us to take
that same technique.
Learn by example, not
by rote, and apply it
to business problems.
Think about your factories, your
customer data, your sales data,
where there is hidden value
and connections in your data
that you're not
taking advantage of.
ML and AI lets us do that.
So we've built a complete
platform around AI and ML.
At the bottom is all
that same infrastructure
that you heard about earlier.
The network, the
compute, the storage.
Because at the
end of the day, ML
is a real big data
and compute problem.
On top of that, we build
platforms, libraries,
and tools, tools that let
you take your business data
and train your own models
without having to worry about
how to scale them, or
how to deploy them,
or how to manage them.
And at the top, we've taken
those very same services
that we offer
consumers, services
that help build systems that
see, hear, speak, listen,
and we've given
those to you by APIs.
So you don't even have to
be able to spell ML in order
to build systems that
can see, hear, speak.
And that lets you match
the tool for the job.
If you are an ML
researcher, and you
want to be on the
cutting edge of defining
how machine learning
works, you can use
our open source SDK TensorFlow.
If you're a data
scientist in your company,
you can use Cloud ML
Engine to build and train
models using TensorFlow
but without having
to get into the details
of how you build and scale
the infrastructure.
And if you're an
application developer,
you can use a simple API to
build vision, speech, text,
hearing, directly into
your applications.
To give you an
example of that, I
want to show you
an example of using
those perception-- those Vision
APIs inside a real application.
So to do that, I'm going
to have Lee come back up,
and she is going to show you an
application that actually knows
how to see, hear, and speak.
Lee.
Lee?
LEE BOONSTRA: Thank you, Greg.
Thank you Greg.
I'm actually very excited to
show the Vision API to you
because, yeah, I'm
not a data scientist.
I'm an app developer.
So I can still play around
with machine learning,
and I don't need to
train my own models.
No, it's pre-trained.
It's pre-trained by Google,
so I can just use it.
I can just make an API call,
and I pass in an image,
usually you upload an image
in a Cloud Storage bucket,
and then I make a
Vision API call,
and the Vision API
can detect the photo.
And it can see landmarks,
it can see persons,
it can see objects.
It gives you all that
information back,
OCR detection, it's very nice.
So that is something I'd
like to show you today.
I created, over the
weekend, a simple app where
I uploaded two pictures here.
I uploaded a photo of a landmark
and a photo of a person.
So let's have a look into
the landmark picture first.
Now, I thought for this
presentation today,
my coworkers, they
made this photo,
and they say it's Munich.
But yeah, I was
actually wondering,
is this indeed Munich,
or did they just
take a normal picture from
another beautiful European city
and put that in the slide deck?
So what I did is I made
a screenshot of it,
and I uploaded it into a bucket.
And then I checked it
with the Vision API.
The Vision API first gives
me back color information.
OK, that can be handy
if you're a designer
and maybe you want to
dynamically build your page.
You have a dark
background and you
don't want to have
a dark photo on it,
so color information
could be handy.
But it also recognized
it is indeed a landmark.
It recognized this is a city.
It gave me back a latitude
and longitude coordinate.
And with that, I can
plot it on a Google map,
so that is what I did.
And yes, it's indeed Munich,
and to be very precise,
it's actually in
the [INAUDIBLE],,
if I pronounce it correctly.
So, yeah, that's
kind impressive.
I thought, that's cool.
What else?
It did recognize some labels
of what it did see, and yeah,
and I translated it.
It's in English, but I connected
it to the Translate API
so that I get the labels
now back in German.
And it tells me,
yeah, it's a tower.
It's a [INAUDIBLE].
I'm 86% sure it's that.
That's the confidence level.
The confidence level says
it's 85% sure it's a city.
So yeah, that's
probably correct.
And it also has
the OCR detection,
so it detected the
welcome in Munich.
OK.
Now, let's do the same example
again but with a person.
And I picked a Dutch
guy, but you guys
might know him as well.
Right?
Yeah.
I thought this was
pretty impressive,
that Vision API did, because
the labels that it gave me back,
it actually recognized
this is a soccer player.
It's 83% sure it
is a soccer player.
And I thought that's
pretty impressive
because I don't see any
soccer balls, or no footballs,
here on this picture.
I just see some green grass, but
that could be any other sport
as well.
So, like, the Vision
API did understand,
like, yeah, that's
a soccer player.
It's definitely a player, it
has something to do with sport,
I see grass, I see team
sport, so that's cool.
But what the Vision
API did not do
is it did not have
facial recognition.
It did not tell me who
this person actually is.
But we are Google, right?
And we know what other
pages on the internet
make use of this photo.
And based on that, we can
also get some entities.
And here, it says it's
actually Arjen Robben,
and he's from the
Bayern Munich team.
And this picture was made
in the Wembley Stadium
and it had something to
do with the European Cup.
That's pretty cool.
Now--
[APPLAUSE]
Now obviously, this is
just a simple demo, right?
But you can imagine
that when you
want to use this in a
real life use case--
let's say you have
a hotel website
and you paid your
photographer to make
pictures of these hotel rooms.
You don't want other websites,
other hotel websites,
to steal your pictures, right?
So you could use the
Vision API, for example,
to detect what
other websites are
making use of your pictures.
Another example could
be in real estate
where you make a
photo of a house,
and that immediately sends you
to the website of the house
listing and says, yeah,
this house is for sale.
Our customers are doing that.
Or maybe in financ--
you have lots of documents
with a lot of text in there.
Can be handwritten
text, can be typed text,
and we use the OCR detection
to get all the text out
of the documents.
So there are lots and
lots of examples here.
This is why I'm so
excited about it.
I'd like to hand
it back to Greg.
Thank you.
GREG DEMICHILLIE:
Thank you, Lee.
[APPLAUSE]
It was really great to see
so many different APIs is
brought together in one
simple to use application.
Now that's what we're
building at Google.
I think it's really useful
to hear what customers
are doing with ML and AI.
And so I'm really pleased to
bring on stage a customer who
knows something about
machine learning
and how to turn it
into business value.
She's the co-founder of one
of Europe's most exciting
new start-ups, dealing with
customers as interesting
as Porsche.
And she did all
this while building
out her bachelor's
degree in E-commerce.
Please join me giving a warm
welcome to Michelle Skodowski
from BOTfriends.
Michelle.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MICHELLE SKODOWSKI: Thank you.
Good morning, everyone.
So I'd like to start
with a little story.
There are many
companies out there
that people crave to work for.
And I believe that Porsche
is maybe one among these.
As generations y
and z are becoming
older and ready to
enter business world,
it becomes more and
more natural to them
to inform themselves about
career opportunities,
not only via website
or email, but simply
on social media such as
writing Facebook Messenger.
All right.
So that's the jobs and
career Facebook Messenger.
And what we can see
here is that someone
is asking questions regarding
internships at Porsche.
All right, after checking
the requirements,
he unfortunately sees that
he doesn't really fit them,
but however, he asks for
more details on dual studies.
All right, he gets led to
a integrated [INAUDIBLE]
and he can check on all
the offers on dual studies.
So that is really, really easy.
He instantly receives
all the answers he wants.
So the special thing here
is that there is actually
no real employee writing back.
But this cute robot here on
the ride, and it's a Chatbot.
And he's the first Chatbot
in the automotive industry,
instantly answering questions
regarding job offers,
internships, dual
studies, et cetera,
by using Google's natural
language processing service,
Dialogflow.
And just last week, we've been
nominated, oh no, actually, we
won the human
resources Excellence
Award in HR tech and
data with this product.
So what we do.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
So what we do at BOTfriends
is we create conversations
over messaging
platforms, but also
voice assistance, with the help
of artificial intelligence.
So our goals are to meet
higher customer expectations
on 24/7 availability,
and also to establish
messaging platforms as a
new way of communication.
Since we spent 90% of our
time on email and messaging
platforms, and since
the time we spent
there has actually surpassed the
time we spent on social media.
And we know that
Facebook Messenger
has reached over
1.3 billion users,
so that's quite impressive.
But now, why did we
choose the Google Cloud
Platform to develop such
an innovative product?
So obviously, one
of the first reason
is, we already talked about
this today, the Google Cloud
Platform is super secure, and
for companies such as Porsche,
this is really, really crucial.
We are also using all the
amazing Natural Language
APIs provided by Google,
such as the Translation API.
For companies such
as Porsche, it
is important to reach all
their potential applicants,
because we know that people
with different backgrounds,
cultures, perspectives,
are definitely contributing
to the company's success and
we can enable conversations
with everyone, regardless
of language and origin.
We are also able to
run [INAUDIBLE] tests
on the App Engine, which is so
crucial for our MVP approach.
So by distributing the
traffic on different Chatbots,
we can see which one
is performing the best,
and which one is the one
we should actually further
develop.
And most importantly, we are
able to scale up automatically
with the [INAUDIBLE]
environment.
So the Chatbot can handle
endless conversations
at the same time,
and our developers
are able to focus on
what they do the best.
Write the code instead of
being busy balancing the load.
All right, so after we
launched that product,
we've seen amazing results.
The great service
Porsche provided
has led to an increased
engagement by over 100%,
and a reduced
workload by over 25%.
So employees at
Porsche were actually
able to focus on more
complex requests.
After the launch,
we are planning
to use the PostgreSQL
database to enable
creating user profiles so
we can offer subscriptions
to job vacancies.
So Porsche fans will
always stay up to date
whenever their
dream job comes up.
And last but not least, we want
to use a sentiment analysis
API by Google to
enable human handovers.
So whenever a
conversation escalates,
let's say the customer is
not happy with the Chatbot
or the conversation,
is unsatisfied,
we can just easily direct
him to a real employee
to escalate the conversation.
The last thing I
have to say, if you
want to hire the best
people, provide them
with a great service.
And with the Google
Cloud Platform,
we've been able to develop
such an innovative product.
Thank you very much,
and have a great day.
[APPLAUSE]
GREG DEMICHILLIE:
Thanks so much, Michell.
Thank you so much.
That's just such a
great example, again,
of tying together all these
machine learning capabilities
in a way that really
makes a difference.
So that's really just
a snapshot of what
we try to do to help you
accelerate your business.
I could have talked about
application development.
There's so many different ways.
But I really do think,
at the end of the day,
we can help you get more value
out of what really is the most
valuable thing you have.
As someone said earlier, it's
the data in your data center
that matters, not the
data center itself.
And so we really think
that we can help you
by building out
a set of products
to let you find value
out of that data.
So now I want to turn over
to the next section of today,
which is to talk about how
you build a partnership
relationship.
Building a relationship
with a Cloud provider
isn't just a short
term relationship.
It's a long term
one, and you want
to have somebody who's in there
with you every step of the way.
So to talk about
partnership and the role
that we think we
can play in that,
please welcome Tom Grey from
Google to talk about that.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
TOM GREY: Thank you, Greg.
And thank you all for coming.
I'm really, really
excited to be here.
I think this is an
extremely exciting time.
And I'm here to talk to you a
little bit about partnership.
We believe that customers are
looking for something new.
They're looking for
new technologies.
They're looking for new business
platforms, new business models.
They're looking for a new
place to do new things.
But they're also looking for
a new partner, a new partner
with a new approach.
Over the course of
this presentation,
we've looked at the
different aspects
of digital transformation.
We've talked about how you
optimize your business.
We talked about how you
divest the parts of the IT
organization, and
technologies that
aren't differentiating to you.
We've talked about
how to collaborate.
We've talked about how
you use collaboration
to accelerate and
to drive innovation
in your organization.
And we've talked about
how you use data.
And you can use data to
differentiate your business.
At Google, we believe we have
one of the foremost platforms
to allow you to do those things.
We believe that
it's at the cutting
edge in terms of capability,
in terms of reliability,
in terms of security.
But we also believe
that that is not enough.
We believe that
to be successful,
you also need a
partner, a partner that
understands the
journey, but also
a partner that understands
the destination.
At Google, I'm proud that we
have 18 years of innovation
behind us, and I'm
confident that we
have many more ahead of us.
In that time, we've
had the chance
to build some of the
leading platforms for mail,
some of the leading platforms
for search, for mobile.
Heck, we've even got to
build self-driving cars.
We've had the chance
to try some things
that, really, many
people only dream of.
And we've also had the chance
to, frankly, make some mistakes
that, really, few
could afford to make.
And that's what we want to
bring to this partnership.
We want to bring and we
want to share that learning.
We want to share
that experience.
At Google, we have a saying.
Focus on the user, and
all else will follow.
We want to build a platform
that focuses on you.
We want to build a
platform that's flexible,
a platform that's open.
We want to build a platform
that has easy to understand,
customer friendly billing.
We want to build a platform that
enables you to build and to run
the applications
you want to run,
but also the applications
that you need to run.
We want to put you in
control of your IT.
To give you some examples
of how we're doing that,
I want to talk about our
sustained usage billing.
So sustained usage
discounts is a scheme
whereby the more you
use of our Cloud,
the less we charge you per unit.
We want to make billing simple.
And so with sustained
usage discounts,
those discounts are
applied automatically.
You don't have to do anything.
You just use the Cloud,
and we automatically
work out what you
should be discounted,
and we apply that
discount on your behalf,
without you needing
to lift a finger.
We also want to
make it flexible.
So we offer that
sustained usage discount
without any kind of commitment
upfront on your part,
whatsoever.
So it's a simple,
it's a flexible,
it's a customer centric
model for billing, we feel.
We're also extremely
committed to openness
and to open standards.
Google as a company was
born on the internet,
and the internet was
born of open standards,
and it's thrived as a result.
We are deeply, deeply committed
to openness, and we're
deeply committed to allowing
you to avoid vendor lock-in.
Vendor lock-in kills innovation.
Vendor lock-in kills innovation
because it doesn't allow
the best technologies to win.
And lastly, people.
As I said before, we have
some amazing people in Google,
and some amazing people that
really have the chance to build
some really amazing things.
And we want to bring
these people to you.
We want you to work
together with these people
to build the next generation
of crazy cool stuff
on the internet.
And you might say, that's great.
Crazy, cool, I love it.
That's kind of
cool, that's great.
But come on, Tom.
What about everything else?
We understand we need
to run that as well.
We need to make it easy
to bring new stuff,
but we also need to make it easy
for you to bring your existing
applications and your existing
investments onto our Cloud
as well.
Globally, CIOs are moving
to the Cloud to save money,
but they're coming
and they're finding
better security, better
reliability, better
flexibility.
We need to make it easy for
you to bring those applications
to our Cloud.
But we also want to
make sure that when
you bring those
applications to the Cloud,
we also make it easy for
you to migrate and to also
take advantage of the new
services that you find there,
services like the DLP,
the data loss prevention
API, services like
Cloud Spanner.
We want to enable you to
migrate and then to modernize.
And we know that
we need to invest
in the people, and the
processes, and the tools
to allow you to do that.
And one example of that is
our support for Windows.
I hope here everybody
would accept and agree
that our platform is an
amazing place to run Linux.
It's an amazing place to
run Open Source workloads.
There's also a lot of
Windows out there, right?
We need to enable people
to run that as well.
So we've made
investments in things
like supporting images
for Windows server.
Many different flavors
of Windows Server,
many different flavors of SQL
server as standard images.
We support hosting
Active Directory,
so that you can extend your own
Premise Active Directory domain
controller, into the Cloud.
For Windows developers,
we want to be
able to use the same,
familiar, powerful tools
that you're used to using.
So then we now
support Visual Studio.
You can develop your
applications in Visual Studio,
and you can easily
deploy them to our Cloud.
The Cloud SDK supports over
100 different commandlets
for the Windows
Power Shell to enable
to use the tools that
you're familiar with to work
in our environment.
And one of the areas we've
made the biggest investment
is in people.
We know we need to bring
people to this partnership
to help you to be successful.
People like our customer
engineering and our solution
architecture teams,
experts who can
work with you to
build, and to design,
and architect your applications
to get the best out
of our Cloud.
People like the
amazing engineers
who sit in our
support organization.
First class Google engineers,
who enjoy deep relationships
with our software
engineering and our site
reliability engineering teams,
so that when things go wrong,
and things will occasionally
go wrong, we can get you up
and running as fast
as we possibly can.
People like our
office at the CTO.
Seasoned industry professionals
with deep technical expertise
and a background in
different verticals,
who can work with customers
who are doing some
of the largest, most audacious
migrations to the Cloud,
migrations where deep technical
expertise and domain expertise
are vital to be successful.
People like our customer
liability engineers,
taking the lessons we've
learned with site reliability
engineering, running those
1 billion user applications,
keeping those up and
running on the internet.
People who can work
with you to bring
the same level of resilience and
security to your applications
so that you can build
applications that stay secure,
that stay scalable, that
stay available under the most
extreme of conditions.
And lastly, Open Source.
We have a lot of experience
with Open Source,
and we can leverage
that experience
to help you with your
Open Source packages,
be that on our Cloud,
or be that on Premise.
So to finish, I
just wanted to talk
through an example of this.
And a great example
of this is Conrad.
Conrad's a 90-year-old
family owned company.
And about 20 years ago, they
made a very smart investment,
and they started to
invest in E-commerce.
And today, Conrad is one
of the leading electronics
suppliers both in
physical stores,
but also on the internet.
They are now working
with Google to move
more and more of those
systems into our Cloud.
Their IoT platform runs on
Google's Cloud and integrates
with Google Assist.
They have moved 5,000
of their employees
to our G Suite platform to allow
them to better collaborate,
to allow them to be empowered.
And they save 90% of
people work in the process,
which is pretty cool.
But lastly, and most
importantly of all,
they're working in
collaboration with us
to explore new business models,
to explore new possibilities,
and to test out the
bleeding edge of what
we are making available.
And I would urge you to go
and check out their booth.
They have a very cool
booth downstairs,
so go say hi to the
folks from Conrad
and hear a little bit more
about their IoT platform.
So in that, I hope
I've given you
a bit of a flavor
of how we're working
in partnership with you, how
we believe in openness, how
we believe in bringing people
and bringing our expertise.
I think it's an
extremely exciting time
to be a technologist.
I'm excited.
I hope you're all excited, too.
And with that, I'm going
to hand back to Michael.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
MICHAEL KORBACHER:
Thank you, Tom.
Thank you.
Yeah, so we spent the
last hour and a half
on talking about four subjects,
four very important subjects,
on your journey in
making the digital move.
Optimize.
Focus on the things
that differentiate you.
Get rid of some of the
things that you shouldn't do.
Collaborate.
I think that's pretty obvious.
We want to make sure we get
more productive, work better
together.
Engage and innovate and look
at the things of the future.
Accelerate.
Look at things like complex data
analytics, machine learning,
and AI, and do that with
a partner that cares.
The future of the Cloud is now.
It's not if, it's
when, and when is now.
I want to leave you with
an overview of what you
can experience this afternoon.
There are going to be
many sessions in four
different tracks, and
you're ready to choose.
There will be plenty of booths
outside from out of partners,
as well as a start-up
booth out there,
as well as a booth that says
ask an architect, where you'll
meet with some of
our technical experts
and you can talk
through architectures.
Some of you have
already started.
I've been curious
to share experience
on the hashtag Google
Summit, Munich.
And I want to leave you
with a little assignment
for the afternoon.
Take one of the
opportunities you
have in mind, one
of the business
opportunities you have in
mind, and take this opportunity
with you into the sessions that
you'll follow this afternoon.
And think about, how does this
session and what I'm hearing,
how does that apply
to my opportunity?
And make sure you
walk out of here today
with something that
you're going to do
different tomorrow that
is going to help you
in fulfilling this idea.
That said, I release
you into the afternoon,
and I look forward
to seeing you again
at our cocktail
reception at 6:15.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]